l'heure est au bilan pour le château de
versailles l'année 2016 a été difficile
avec une baisse du tourisme étranger de
6% mais les fêtes de fin d'année ont été
plutôt bonnes pour le château avec un
taux de fréquentation d'environ 10% en
est à 6 millions 700 mille visiteurs ce
qui mène déjà un très beau chiffre par
rapport à 7 millions et demi l'année
dernière et ses six millions 7 se
décompose en 4 millions de visiteurs au
château par rapport à 4 millions et demi
à peu près l'année précédente
un million trois cent mille pour les
trianon et les jardins et 1 million 400
mille pour les spectacles ce qui veut
dire aussi que versailles a cette
particularité d'être multiculturelle et
d'offrir une offre de programmation très
diversifiée et donc les spectacles ont
permis de compenser aussi un peu dans
une période plus morose et plus
difficile avec des publics plus locaux
plus franciliens pour pallier à cette
baisse le château a mis en place
plusieurs stratégies la première attirer
des touristes français grâce à des
partenariats avec des offices de
tourisme comme celle de paris mais aussi
créer un lien de proximité avec les
touristes étrangers qui représentent 60
% de la fréquentation annuelle
nous nous tournons vers nos visiteurs
traditionnels qu'il s'agisse des états
unis mais c'est aussi une politique
d'exposition ambitieuse vers l'ex vers
l'étranger ou le château sorte de ses
murs habituel pour aller montrer une
grande partie de ses collections pas
toujours visible pour tous nous pour
tous nos visiteurs habituellement c'est
le cas au japon en ce moment avec une
exposition sur marie antoinette qui se
déroule jusqu en mars qui a déjà
accueilli à tokyo deux cent mille
visiteurs à la fin d'année et puis une
autre exposition en australie à canberra
qui a démarré il ya peu près de
maintenant trois semaines qui marchent
également très très bien et qui vise à
démontrer que le musée ne se fige pas
non plus dans ces lieux la stratégie
marketing de 2017 est simple continuer
les expositions à l'étranger pour
développer la notoriété du château de
versailles